hartos de tener que cuadrar los gastos y
los beneficios cada día por el
incremento del precio de la gasolina y
por el cambio la tarifa del servicio de
taxi a los clientes los taxistas han
decidido hoy salir a manifestarse y
cortar las calles del centro de beirut
para reclamar mejores laborales
hemos pagado más de 25 mil dólares por
la licencia del taxi y al final del día
no conseguimos juntar más de 10 dólares
como vamos a mantener a nuestras
familias tenemos al gobierno un
ultimátum para que atendieran nuestras
demandas pedimos a las autoridades
competentes una solución porque si no
Seguiremos paralizando la ciudad con los
taxis
los taxistas también se quejan de la
competencia desleal de los conductores
privados sin licencia que trabajan en
compañías como bolt o como Uber
Y a ti con la leo estamos aquí porque
hay compañías ilegales que están
quitándonos el trabajo no podemos
competir con sus precios Porque estos
conductores no pagan licencia le hemos
pedido en muchas ocasiones al gobierno
que ponga un control con las matrículas
no deberías permitir a los vehículos con
placa azul operar con taxis es ilegal
los taxistas evaneses se exigen una
regulación de los servicios de
transporte público pero con unos
ministerios a medio gas por la crisis
política que mantiene paralizada la
formación de un gobierno difícilmente
podrán ver mejorías pero sin embargo han
amenazado con que seguirán con las
protestas